so this will be you know the last talk
of the morning so it's my pleasure to
introduce a future man I will talk to us
about a simplified Voronoi algorithm
thank you very much for the introduction
and for inviting me I'm very happy to be
here and learn so much this week was
very nice and I'm also very happy that
vessel gave already parts of my talk so
I can go fast over the first few notions
actually I can jump directly from
lettuces to quadratic forms or gray
matrices and you know already what
perfect gray matrix perfect form is the
minimum the arithmetic L minimum is the
squared length of a minimal vector and
so I will do everything in the language
of gray matrices and quadratic forms
because vessel already did the job for
jumping there a little bit has to be
said here because my n is his D there's
a little bit of a difference but other
than that we have similar notions Q is
supposed to be positive definite and
then we have a perfect Q if and only is
if it is uniquely determined by the
arithmetic minimum and the
representatives or the minimal vectors
and he also had the notion of a Voronoi
domain which I call Voronoi cone and
he's a full dimensional if and only if Q
is perfect and then there's this
classical theory by Voronoi which tells
us that these Voronoi cones give like a
nice tessellation of the cone of
positive semi-definite positive definite
matrices and there are only finitely
many up to gln z equivalents so it's
kind of a short version of the
introduction by vessel to remind you and
Voronoi was actually interested in
reduction theory for lettuces or
quadratic forms in this case and from
these Voronoi cones you can obtain like
a fundamental domain by splitting it up
up to the action of g ln z on the space
of positive definite quadratic forms so
the base changes in lettuces correspond
to these jumps here in the space of
positive definite quadratic forms from
form q to an equivalent form u transpose
qu and now the idea is to adapt this
algorithm of Voronoi which Vessel talked
about to get certificates for some form
lying in one of these cones so i want as
an input matrix some some quadratic form
were gray matrix
lying somewhere and then i want to find
the cone which contains that and i can
adapt this Voronoi algorithm to find
this cone you know simplex kind of way I
go from cone to cone until I find this
corresponding Veronica in this classical
setting this doesn't make much of a new
thing because it's basically giving a
certificate for something being positive
definite but there are other ways to
prove that something is positive
definite by computing the eigenvalues
etc but we want to do this in another
setting for other codes so I want to
generalize this and I also want to
generalize this notion of a risk of
polyhedron which this was mentioned
which is used to kind of do this search
of cones it's a dual picture to the
Voronoi cone picture and the vertices
correspond here to these perfect forms
and then the paranoia algorithm can be
seen as the
traversal search on this each graph of
this risk of polyhedron so vertices
correspond to perfect forms you start
with one and then you explore this graph
until you don't find any you once and as
he said there are a lot of shortest
victor problems to be solved in order to
see what the facets are locally and in
order to find neighboring vertices you
also need a lot of shorter Specter
problems then you test whether or not
this is already known this is a lettuce
isometry problem but actually the
bottleneck in this classical setting as
he mentioned already is this polyhedra
representation conversion so given
facets of a polyhedron find the
generating race so this is kind of a
classical important problem in
combinatorial optimization or
combinatorial polytope theory and this
is actually the bottleneck here why this
doesn't work in dimension 9/10 et cetera
so shortest vector problems is not such
a difficulty here but in how a
generalization it will be and that's
actually the reason why I give this talk
here because there is a version of the
shortest vector problem which I can't
solve quickly and I thought this might
be the audience where some people have
ideas how to solve that in a better way
ok so this is the reminder of what
Vessel talked about already if you have
any questions up to this point I'm happy
to answer that just because there are
many many facets or no deficits the
number of minimum vectors is but the
problem is there are these high
dimensional highly symmetric lettuces
like the e8 root lettuce and then you
have in these cases polyhedra which have
a lot of generate
race even up to symmetries and in
dimension eight the main objective is to
find like this generating race of the e8
polyhedron so to say which has hundreds
20 facets because they are 240 pins or
two times hundred twenty minimal vectors
but an enormous amount of race even up
to symmetries and mature has like
special code for computing race up to
symmetries and has developed over the
years some techniques to kind of solve
these problems so we were able to do
this up two-dimensional okay that's the
old story we want to generalize this now
to a setting where I replaced the cone
of positive semi-definite matrices by
other crowns so in particular I'm
interested in this completely positive
cone which is kind of a part of the
positive semi-definite cone so instead
of looking at the cone generated by all
these rank one matrices I just take
those which have non-negative entries
here so positive semi-definite would be
the cone which comes from all vector 6x
and now I'm just taking a sub cone here
so in this two-dimensional picture
N equals two we have simply the half of
this three-dimensional cone and it's
still split into Veyron electrons and
the dual cone becomes bigger it's called
the co+ cone and now generalizing this
Voronoi algorithm works by having
decomposition into Voronoi cones in this
small cone and a risk of polyhedron in
the dual cone so kind of you split into
two worlds so to say which were
previously in one cone in the semi
definite case we just work in one cone
because this is self do
so in order to generalize we now need a
notion of co+ minimum etc so but let me
tell you about an application first or
why we are interested in this so this
comes up in co+ optimization which is
kind of chronic optimization problem the
class of convex optimization problems
which generalize linear programming so
this is like a linear programming
standard form where cone for linear
programming would be the non-negative
real vectors and if we replace this cone
by other cones we get things like semi
definite programming or co+ programming
which is obtained when we take this cone
to be this cone of completely positive
or positive matrices and one difficult
thing there is to give like a
certificate for something to be Co
positive and or completely positive and
we want to use this Voronoi adaption to
prove that a given matrix is completely
positive so we want to give like a
certificate for a given input matrix a a
we want to write it like a rational
rational linear combination of rank one
matrices sorry
which are non-negative so X should be a
finite set non-negative vectors so we're
looking for something like that this can
be used as a certificate that something
is completely positive and that's
exactly saying this is living in a cone
like these Voronoi cones okay so we need
to generalize the notion of minimum
notion of perfectness the notion of the
risk of polyhedron now to this for
positive setting and this version of the
shortest vector problem I was mentioning
is this cop SVP so the problem of
finding the co positive minimum of a cop
positive quadratic form and this is
quite difficult to compute deciding
whether or not something is positive is
already Co and P complete so far we
don't know exactly what the difficulty
is and we only have a very naive bad
algorithm to solve this at all
so based on a result Bible foes in doer
we can kind of split the problem into a
finite number of classical shortest
vector enumerations so what we do is
like we take standard simplex so which
is kind of generating set for the
or negative autumns then we can like
look at it and if on this impacts the
form the input form is non-negative we
can do a numeration it's not
non-negative on this cone we have to
split this cone and find a subdivision
on which this is non-negative so to say
so for instance if we have e3 transpose
times Q times e2 less than zero then
this condition of being non-negative on
the complete cone is not satisfied on
this edge and we therefore split the
edge here and have to sub simply C's now
we check with the new vertex here if the
two sub simply C's are having this
property that it's non-negative okay we
can do a classical enumeration shortest
vector problem there if it's not we have
to split further this into simply C's
and we have some flexibility in how to
split but the problem is that for
general input this kind of splitting is
very intense so there is a lot of
splitting super exponential many
certification was a verification I will
show you the Voronoi algorithm in a
second where we use this and this comes
up in all kinds of steps there so if you
find a neighboring cone you need this
shortest vector problem so it's kind of
like the motor for the whole Barone or
algorithm no not at all so we want exact
so my main question to the audience is
can we find a better algorithm for this
shortest vector problem because this is
the motor for our certificate
algorithm which I'll show you now so
this is kind of like my add-on to the
open problem session I mean you should
be able to
I haven't managed to do it but I'm sure
you could
there must be some better ways I'm sure
so this notion of perfectness and the
risk of polyhedron we can generalize
simply by instead of saying that
arithmetic Oh minimum should be greater
equal one we just replace it by the co+
minimum being greater equal one and
perfectness is defined over this co+
minimum so something is called cop for
positive perfect if and only if it is
uniquely determined by the Co positive
minimum and the vector is attaining it
and then we again get like a locally
finite polyhedron like this risk of
polyhedron which is a little bit
different because now we have some x
rays which point to nowhere so which we
call dead ends which giving oops assets
of the dual cone sometimes and but we
have perfectness is again equivalent to
being a vertex there and we want is
really a Voronoi algorithm now
completely the same as in the classical
case with these notions as a starting
point we can take this lattice quadratic
form coming from the a a and root
lettuce it's easy to see that this is a
Koch perfect thing because the minimal
vectors are non-negative and so we have
a starting point in every dimension we
have a Voronoi cone and if our input is
in there we are done if it's not in
there we do this simplex type jumping to
the neighboring counts
and the algorithm now looks like that
the Voronoi simplex type algorithm and
here
now the co+ shortest vector problem is
really the bottleneck everything else is
kind of easy-peasy
but this is the real problem
computationally so we need it
in order to find this local situation to
find the facets of the rushkoff
polyhedron at a given vertex and we
needed to find the neighboring vertices
and there it is used extensively several
of these computations even dimension 6 7
8 it becomes somehow solve it over the
the integers like I mean if you need it
to certify for positivity
because here you know that your forms
right I mean it helps in the sense that
we can use like this classical
enumeration techniques to just go
through the integer vectors right we
don't have to check all the real vectors
but still I mean enumeration is already
painful and if we have to do this
enumeration and all of the simply C's in
all of these simple counts it's becoming
too much in practice at the moment
so I bet there are easy ways to make
this faster you wrist eclis and with a
lot of tricks known from the shorter
Specter community but I'm not an expert
in this so that's why I'm proposing this
is a problem here
yeah there's again a polyhedra
representation conversion which tells us
which directions we can go and actually
they're like in the classical simplex
algorithm for linear programming we also
have some choices we can go different
paths we don't have to take one specific
cone but sometimes we have choices to
make and it's not clear which choices
are best like in the classical linear
programming we also have the problem of
not knowing what kind of pivot rule
what kind of neighboring rule is good
okay let me explain this algorithm on a
few little pictures it's maybe easier
than looking at just the text so the
interior cases as I said is simply
solving these shortest victor problems
and then finding a neighboring cone
until you hit your input so in this case
after one step one iteration we are done
and then the certificate that the input
is completely positive looks like that a
little bit more difficult the boundary
cases and actually we are giving the
first algorithm I think that gives a
certificate for any input that has a
rational decomposition and for the
boundary cases it is not clear which
kind of pivot rule leads you there but
by going to a breadth search rest for
breadth-first search you can at least
guarantee that the algorithm terminates
at the boundary at some point so we have
first algorithm for giving certificates
in case there are rational CP
factorizations oh right the rational
input like this for the exterior cases
we are still missing a proof that our
algorithm ends with a certificate but we
believe that also for input matrices
which are not completely positive our
algorithm gives like a certificate after
some time namely it ends with a perfect
form which has an inner product with the
input matrix which is negative proving
that it's outside the dual cone practice
this works well but we don't have a
proof that this always works so far so
let me resume with some open questions
and to do so we are looking at these
pivot rules that's one one obstacle but
one main thing in order to speed up
practical computations would be to have
better ways of obtaining these shortest
vectors for the co+ case
it's really the main open problem in
this field I think
the end I like to thank you for your
coming and
[Applause]
general question for perfect or
corporate forms you are interested
mainly in the analysis by the min Q but
the number of times this min Q is say if
I go to the geometry I'm interested by
the packing density but also by the
kissing number now we don't know how the
kissing number is behaving with the
density here can you say something about
if I take perfect forms or can we say
something about the dimension yeah I
think kissing number will give you an
upper bound because you can always like
extend two letters and plastic me for
general lattices we we know from the
tables that it is increasing and
probably exponential number yeah I would
assume there should be a bound like that
in terms of the classical kissing number
but we don't have it just perfect forms
can I say something about this since in
the general case I cannot I don't know
so this setting is brand new
and we haven't thought about it but
there should be similar like for the
number of the problem here is that we
don't have like a reduction right
there's no group action so there's
something different we don't have like
there's a basis which have has small
code and it's or something like that but
in that there's this coordinate
permutations but it's just a finite
group and not as much as c ln z
I mean it's an interesting problem to
generalize notions from the geometry of
numbers in this setting maybe look how
far you can generalize which I didn't
have so far thank you
all right
[Applause]